okay so Aristotle starts off with this
is famous dictum beginning of the decade
board behind me every day mark and every
inquiry and similarly every action in
pursuit is thought to aim that good and
it sounds very commonsensical we're
going to talk about Aristotle what he
actually has to contribute but that's
what that's a very important thing to
remodel everything that we're involved
with involves a purpose of activity we
often said so part of what we're going
to do tonight is maybe add the nature of
purpose of activity not just a bunch of
examples plan at least what wonderful
ossifer thinks it consistent and we will
get a lot of trying to apply it to your
your own life into your profession but
we're looking at something into wider I
wanted to start out actually by using
the example you're all familiar with
this right the heroes culinary arts
skopje and this is what kind of more
yeah it was an English translation
indeed so what does the yeah it's it's
it's a cookbook it's a ton of recipes
when I first read through it I was
expecting you know that they were going
to talk so much about of Skopje well
here I'll actually get his philosophy
I'll get his whole view on things and no
one's dead it's mostly bunch of recipes
and there are there are some discussions
about why sauces you know what should be
done for as much we've done last the
cookbook is an artifact and it's sort of
a nexus a locus of purpose of activity
if you want to know how to make
something we just open this up at random
if you want to make hot eggs for
luncheon order well there it is on page
165 right you just follow the recipe and
sometimes they have parts that you have
to look up in other places but it's
reduced to technique and the questions
of why you would do things this way you
know what why this man why you want to
do this in one way rather than another
they're not really in certified so
they're sort of assumed or set to the
side it's interesting the cookbooks are
one of the first kinds of technology
that we have that gets called technology
Aristotle actually is going to coin
technology and you didn't point it to
talk about bloggers or cameras or
anything like that he actually pointed
to talk about a text books we call the
people who wrote books of rhetoric
little art you know arts of rhetoric
basically like like cookbooks if you
want to get this sort of reaction from
your audience throw this at them if you
want to provoke this sort of thought
process throw this mmm we call those
technological though people who wrote
those and we get our word technology
from that there's a sort of reduction to
technique going on in those and there's
something like that going on and this
this book is isn't very important right
and everybody needs to have a copy it's
going right you know that you go to the
library and you get one if you lose when
you find another way to get one of these
even if you've memorized the whole thing
because it's a part of your camp but
this book will not tell you what to do
as a shout it won't tell you how to make
difficult decisions it won't approach
the bigger things like what career path
should little questions like how should
I live what's what is a good chef not
just in the sense of somebody who has
mastered certain skills but morally good
or good for other people or grew up good
in certain contexts this won't give that
to you so you have to turn to something
else instead at the same time like I
said this is a nexus of a lot of
different purposes and activity why is
this book such a classic why do they
make you read this
is the he was redefined the way
occasions works in the commercial sense
yeah and hid a little knowledge is
important because he it's basically it's
not a guide on how to be a chef but you
can produce a kibbutz the right mindset
I guess I think using a certain
discipline don't look at help you work
things down at it captain okay let's
assume that all that is the case I see
no reason why not to notice that what
you've got there is something that goes
beyond the book itself the book is an
object but it has certain purposes that
go beyond something that has to do with
transformation person into the chef
that's why we should run into this at
one time or another and probably just
not go into it but actually engage or
look over the course of their their
education just like if you want to be a
philosopher while you have to be here
someone sometime might leave on the side
but you certainly have to Rita that's
some now if it's a classic then one of
the things that we're looking at today
is that of excellence this is embodied a
certain kind of excellence right that's
why it's still on the shelves even
though it's fairly old otherwise if
excellence was simply whatever is the
newest thing we throw this out Kofi
himself he thought that it that he
throws but that's not the case so this
embodies a certain kind of excellence
and we're going to look at this notion
of excellence or is eros level called
virtual a little bit later on so I want
to give you an overview of where we're
going to go with this person I want to
say a few words about philosophy in
aerosol what we're doing here today some
of the questions that you gave to be a
professor Shaka I want to
all those at the beginning not
necessarily giving it full answers to
them but at least sort of mapping out
where we're going to go with them and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to tackle some of the material in
units and a kind of sequence so here's
what I'd like to do I'd like to reach
one of these sequences present a little
bit of the text maybe put a few things
on the board and then we'll think about
some examples and we'll look at some
possible applications to your own life
how this actually bears fruit for you
and then we'll do some more sustained
Q&A about this and I want to keep this
sort of on track and you guys are pretty
good at that you know I know that here
at the Culinary things that are supposed
to work like clockwork right I always do
don't they absolutely kitchens never get
behind well sometimes they do that as
much as most places so what are we going
to talk about there's four topics that I
want to get up and as you read through
this you might have sort of seen things
falling out this way but they're not
necessarily tied to just one section in
the next section in the next section
first thing I want to talk about is just
purpose of activity in general this
notion of doing things for a reason
that's part of every human action
everything that we do is done for some
sort of reason so we want to look at
that general idea then we're going to
look at the reason for something bigger
a really philosophical question what's
the purpose of human life in general so
we're going to go from the very specific
to big question
then the Aristotle is the answer to this
involves some reference to wrinkles
virtues and we're going to talk about
that actually get some of the things
that you just wrote for that what does
it call the this I believe yeah your
eyes sure you journal entries in terms
of the qualities that make for good chef
so that we could look at those things so
just the list so we'll look at just a
few of them where I can go over
everybody's think and minor detail
because we got an hour ham so we're
going to look at a few of those and then
we'll look at the intellectual virtues
and I know you guys have a lot of
questions about the connection between
making and doing praxis & Co asus and so
will try to clarify some of that and if
we have time it was some sort of general
Q&A afterwards so if anybody has pull
everything together questions
so if you worked about philosophy before
we start there's a sort of two extremes
that we want to avoid that I say tight
as a lot of misconceptions about
philosophy itself sometimes people and
this comes from our culture where we
often use philosophy in a very loose
manner the term somebody will talk about
well my philosophy of coaching is XYZ or
my philosophy salads is XYZ they don't
mean philosophy in the in terms of the
academic discipline right they're not
talking about philosophy at the same
level that Aristotle's and so sometimes
people think that philosophy just means
coming up with a few ideas and throwing
them around and it's officer
loosey-goosey and anything can mean
anything and anything goes it right
there's no right or wrong I actually saw
somebody to put Facebook one of my
artist friends when I pointed out that
you people miss attributed something to
a philosopher's ago you know not not
only to can we not know about these were
things it doesn't even matter of getting
getting getting right what they said so
if Augustine said this and he says that
he actually said something different
that's because it's all you know
philosophy so it's all whatever we make
it but we're not going to do that right
now the other extreme and we want to
avoid extremes in this the other extreme
is to say oh it's very abstract
discipline and you're never going to be
able to master it or get your head
around it because it's only for the you
know the super elite intellectuals and
Aristotle didn't think that Plato didn't
think that if you read them you see you
know Socrates went around you didn't
just talk with you know people they
thought were smart enough to talk with
we talked with everybody they sort of
test it up can this person measure up to
some of these ideas sometimes people
think that the philosophy is just
irrelevant or
beyond them and I tend to think that
it's a lot of our modern philosophers
who put that internet it's unfortunate
it's just a sort of fact of the
profession but the good news is
Aristotle's not beyond any of you he
hasn't been beyond any students for
about 2,300 years and he's going to
continue not being beyond other students
for millennia so long as you know
society as a collapse so in reality
philosophy is one of the it's one of the
oldest academic disciplines and why is
it state around so long well because it
actually is well it actually does have a
lot of thing when it's done well it can
inform all the other disciplines that
you might study from our stick
disciplines to social sciences to
business pick whatever you want
philosophy of something to contribute to
them again when it's done well there's a
whole body of classical literature and I
had you read a little bit of that in
which it actually is done well now you
know when you read aerosol for the first
time they say well what if this is done
well I don't think I want to read any
for this and actually that would my
reaction when I first read Aristotle I
did I didn't like him his undergraduate
I didn't start liking them as long as a
grad students or reading them not in
translation but in Greek so I can
sympathize with them but he inspired
this body of classic literature and
again it's sort of like a skopje why do
people keep coming back to this it's not
just because he has a sort of cachet you
know name that s copia did you know he's
into your target you transformed things
even the end is maybe we just leave that
environment
this is the new em all there's there's
some changes that come about modernize
the modernizing there's there's still
some other things to this that makes it
a classic it's the same thing for
aerosols the same thing from Plato is
the same thing for any other great
philosopher you're going to read now
requires a lot of work and we're not
going to try to pretend like we're doing
all that work here today this will
require you're doing some thinking and
working on your own and he actually
gives a lot of culinary metaphors for
this epic I might often do when I tell
non-kill culinary students about this I
say that this is stuff you have to sort
of a lot of marinate or we have to
ruminate about it or you have to allow
it to be digested and then you know
become part of the fabric of your mind
and there there's something true to that
now what is Aristotle doing what is the
philosophy are going to contribute some
of the typical things you can see
philosophers doing are looking at things
systematically and again you know
parallels to some of the culinary grades
are along those lines to the skokie a
looked at being systematically didn't he
could have made the revolutionary
changes again if you didn't look at
things as a whole if you only focused in
on that have one station he'd have never
gotten to any of the higher levels let
alone transforming entire kitchen
Aristotle's doing something like that
with ideas with practices and moral
conceptions what else do they do well
they you'll see the aerosol doing this
they take in everybody else's ideas and
then they sort of weigh them they want
to see what's good and what's bad that
makes it difficult to read Aristotle
sometimes you can't tell when he's
actually
forcing an idea himself and wine he is
actually just throwing it out there and
saying well some people say this
sometimes they'll say some people say
this is their dead wrong let me know
ourselves not endorsing it right they'll
say some people are saying this and
there's something to what they're saying
it gets a little tougher that sometimes
you just throws it out there people say
this you don't know actually whether
he's endorsing it or not until you read
other parts of it what else drawing
connections between things that's that's
part of the act of philosophy also
making important distinctions this is
something that we really don't teach
enough in our primary education
secondary education and we don't teach
it an awful lot fanatically in college
drawing good distinctions being able to
say well you're right in this sense but
also wrong in this sense being able to
draw the distinction between performing
a function and performing a function
well oftentimes we collapse things in
together and when we get into arguments
with each other if you actually pay
close attention to what we're arguing
about quite often it turns out that
we've made some assumptions that tied
things together that actually should be
distinguished from each other so we want
to be careful with that naira so does
that there is one other things who I
want to say about this reading selection
a caution that I think I tried to pass
on to the professor shocked at before
and that's your reading stuff that was
written in ancient Greek and then it was
translated by stuffing Oxford guys about
a century there are better translations
but they got public domain why you're
reading
what we've got bless you the the
translations are not always consistent
and they don't always pick the best word
to translate things one of the examples
of this is actually judgment we're going
to talk about that in a few minutes why
there's keeping hang-up about not having
judgment in some things that seem to
actually build require judge I know you
guys talked about that before so I don't
want to say I can't depend on the
translations of all but anytime that you
any time do you think that what
Aristotle just has to be completely off
base here because this sounds completely
stupid it's probably an outing ourselves
fault it's probably the transfer so you
want to be a bit careful with that stuff
that's way of getting around that unless
you actually while our Greek is to
compare translations each other you know
look at a couple of one offhand which
look for will be a little more hassle
you think ah no the reason that I should
but the reason I don't is because if I
want to know what Aristotle sang action
and so I should put the time into like
thinking about that I do know one new
one that just came out that I'm sure is
really good because I actually know one
of the translators because I got a
little pamphlet mail for it the other
day there's something to Professor
that one's actually not not out yet it's
just coming out so we're being offered
the chance to buy achievable professors
by susan collins and then somebody else
of the nikah mchana yeah there are other
great translations i'm not i'm not sure
but you know if you compare translations
with each other a lot of times you can
get a better sense of what's being said
so not what I want to do is I want to
start with some of the questions that
Professor shock a compile from your
session last class and I've got six so
the first one is a pretty broad why did
we read this well it's a good question
to ask I actually sometimes begin my
other classes by asking my students that
and if you want a trivial answer what
would it people while you had to it told
you to now see a spike is that it may be
satisfied for something we have one of
the others it could just be I mean but
at the same time you know like if you
have read any other philosophers then
you understand that in order to be to
represent yourself better or in a
conversationalist
you have to have to read this yeah now
of course you're sort of looking ahead
if this is a book and you're asking them
a lot as an end you aren't reading of
course right other people might say well
I don't know I don't know why I have to
read this but you know I do what they
tell me to do because there's a certain
yes chef mentality and there's a lot of
things that make more sense afterwards
and you understand them you know the
reasons for them later it was like that
in the army to soldier we were told
first do the thing and then worry about
why you do that right after you've done
it then there's not the reason why well
I would be saying that you never get to
that situation and that's that why isn't
it satisfying just to be told because I
said so you do want to know why right
well aerosol talks about that he says in
the metaphysics another one of his books
all human beings desire to know this is
a basic drive some of you actually put
curiosity is going to shush but it's not
just a chef reality it's something that
is part of what makes us human beings
our curiosity was Wade young all the
other animals
tempe kind of curious like cats and it's
like that aerosol has something is
saying about this desire how it plays
itself out he also this is what leads us
to purpose of behavior notice we're
already asking about why what is the
point of doing this what is the goal
what is the net what are we going to
attain Memphis we're already doing what
Aristotle was talking about and asking
why we watch your nearest on kind of
presupposing the beginning of the
inquiry right there what are the
implications for our lives and how do we
apply this in 2012 building two
different questions that I still lumped
in together I notice they are very two
very different questions one is asking
about how to apply this in context the
other ones asking about something very
specific you know how do i how do we
apply this in 2012 one thing I'd like to
say at the start is Aristotle is always
going to say you should apply these
things in context and if what he's
saying is any good get wat to be able to
be applied in contests if it wasn't then
you know sort of like a skull PA would
be mode and say this is no longer
helping him get rid of it it's not a
museum piece your model would let's say
that about his own naked mccain ethics
if you can't find a way to apply it in
present then no longer has any purpose
right now notice though there's a sort
of assumption here though and i'd like
you to think about this he why assume
that matters are so radically different
in 2012 and they were in 1748 or
you know 4th century Greece what he has
changed I mean there's a lot that has
changed right communication technology
technology the technology is really one
of the big ones so the social order has
changed now the question could be asked
that people fundamentally changed
fundamentally done that's where I was
talking about that's why we still read
it because you're right if it was just a
matter of technology then why would we
know that sort of like talking about
elevator operator we want to book for
how to be a good elevator operator do we
have any elevator operators they used to
you don't need them anymore because we
have new technology there's parts of
Aristotle's ethics you may find not
quite so useful because some of it is
dependent on social system but the parts
that I have to do with human nature
haven't really fundamentally changed and
and they're probably not going to in our
lifetime or any conceivable lifetime
here's another good question why is this
so complicated nature wasn't even this
complicated well Nietzsche is actually
that complicated to do it to begin with
if you read through a stub I know
today's to crack my head on him
Heidegger who is major philosopher in
the last century said because Nietzsche
read a lot of aerosol he said if you
want to understand need to study
Aristotle for ten years and then go to
each other and then study nature for ten
years now that's not a very satisfying
answer
the better answer is why is it so
complicated well because reality is
complicated and human beings are the
most complicated parts of reality you
know you might think about technology
like you know I phone think about all
the chips and circuits and all that in
there this is not more complicated than
you are it's not more complicated than
even your brain is but it's certainly
it's not even as complicated as the rest
of your life yeah this is about the best
we could do at this point with super
complicated something we have bigger
computers that's the same general idea
in order to understand human nature you
have to be willing to put in a good
amount of work just as if you want to
understand all the different postures
varieties and sauces you'd actually have
to do an awful lot of cooking wouldn't
you if you want to understand the
chemical processes going on you actually
have to study something about chemistry
so eres level is not needlessly
complicated but it is complicated here's
another interesting one where does the
argument fail now here's something I'd
ask you to turn are you sure this is one
argument here that's something to think
it's out but let's assume that there is
just one argument here what I would like
to say is before you can ask about
whether somebody's position is right or
wrong you have to fully understand the
position you have to really wrap your
head around and then you can you can go
on to criticize it I know that tomato
often our pedagogy is we want to
make everybody critical thinkers all the
time and I actually teach critical
things so I'm for critical thinking but
like Heidegger said criticism
presupposes understanding so what we're
going to do to hear the day mostly it's
just trying to understand Aristotle not
really worrying about how can we find
the holes in this position things like
that oh I will point out some places
where I think these bits of mistakes
another thing that came up how do we
make sense of aerosols distinction
between making and doing or acting or
twice or praxis for culinarians not just
in general deferred for you guys and
we're going to get to this in the fourth
part so I'm going to actually put that a
lot and then another one that came up
what is it air assault associate
judgment from technique or judgment from
practical wisdom from art doesn't that
seem kind of counterintuitive that one's
an easy one to get out of the way that
has to do with Howard translating each
other there's a couple different Greek
words that we would translate his
judgment and what he's talking about
there is the greek word for nana mizuki
no man which has to do a surface for the
capacity to figure things out in
situations where discretion is amiss
called for you see I'm talking about
that at the very end of it that's not to
say that judgment in the broader sense
isn't involved in in skill or arts or
practical reason that would be a
different than that we create DJ the
word that we actually get critic from
the broader sense of it so then there I
have to apologize for that the quinta
texts themselves fall so let's actually
take a punt they do you guys have any
questions at this point before we start
delving in anybody want to be on the
ship what were you actually go under
under the waters now okay well then
let's go and look at this notion of a
purpose of activity so the very first
seven straight there I want actually
look at this kind of careful not going
to do this every single this sentence
because you know that would take a
semester then we have one night but the
words here are important and I actually
do want to point towards certain the
broader 33 times yet so every art my art
you can also translate that as craft or
discipline productive discipline the
greek word is technique the worth of
media technology technique was this wide
thing that covered everything from
salmon making to cooking to medicine in
a certain respect sometimes it would get
mixed up with another term kissed ma
which means knowledge or discipline
aristotle sometimes goes back and forth
a bit with those you know for instance
his strategy and art or is it as we
would say a science say it's more normal
part actually
or horse-breaking you brings it up as an
example of a marked not one that we're
very familiar every inquiry Greek word
there is beth autos where we get method
from that means some sort of structured
inquiry everything that we want to know
about so how are you doing is not
actually an inquiry at that point but
going around and trying to find out how
somebody is progressing with their
illness or we're not progressing in
responding communication that would be
able quick the IRS plaudits you they're
carrying out an inquiry right when you
are tested on things somebody is
inquiring into the knowledge that you're
supposed to get the skills that you're
supposed to so every inquiry every
action that's a very broad term to term
that he's using there is actually praxis
and I want to point out here that era
cell uses practice and arrow stance and
also a broad sense so some of the things
that we talk about in this is production
or is making would fall under that broad
sets of practice but not under the
narrow sense we'll get to that so the
things that you do in the classroom the
culinary class rooms through the baking
and pastry classrooms those are action
you are your producer something are any
of you athletes so Natalie's what you're
doing on out of the field is plotting
when you're playing sort of sports or
game that's action tip
getting yourself here is a action
putting yourself to bed that's action
everything action encompass is just
about everything even choosing to think
about something isn't it certainly an
action sitting down to read that's an
action every pursuit now the word that
is using their that's probably not the
best translation there's a lot of places
later on where he talks about choice
aren't you involving choice the Greek
court there is a crisis Troy raices
literally means to prefer one thing to
another to make a decision this is
better than that to make a commitment
that goes just beyond it goes beyond
just the moment and involves formation
of your character performing who you are
so this ties in very closely with this
these statements of belief who is it
that you actually are that for Aristotle
if there's a large part of product these
choices and what's being translated here
is pursuit so when you see this term
pursuit I think something brought or
brought think about how you perform
yourself think about how you chose to be
on the pathway that's a pursuit in that
sense now he says all of these a mets
own good and you'll use a lot of other
terms a long line he'll talk about
purpose another trick you're going to
see quite often coming up and we're not
quite used to thinking of this is n
usually it only comes up for us and we
say that's a means to an end but what is
in evidence it's what you want to
achieve it's your purpose it's your
breathing yeah sometimes
word product sometimes the word
sometimes the purpose for something is
actually a product is Magic for a lot of
texts what's the product of st. medicine
people killing their health yeah I mean
health in the broad sense of like
bringing everything back to rule out to
be when you're actually sick that means
providing some healing it can be very
specific the nurse who stitches you up
because you fell off a ladder crack your
head open and you know now you actually
have a hole that you know they have to
stitch up um there's a purpose to that
she's she's a producing something way
your head being closed no one you're
bleeding everywhere and then maybe they
give you some painkillers and what's the
purpose of that so you're not hurting so
you can act you can actually do things
so everything that we do is for some
reason he says it aims at some good now
I know notice he also does talk about
when you brought up certain differences
found among n summer activities success
some things we do for their own sake
others are products apart from the
activities that produce them says when
there are ends apart from the actions
it's the nature of the products to be
better than the activities now think
about that crew why do you want to talk
do you like going to the doctor or to
hang out of the doctor's office some
people fight we talked about their
purposes who likes to go to the doctor's
office just to go to the doctor's office
people who want
pathogen attention yeah if you want if
you want help you actually have some
legitimate reason for being the carmaker
people who want attention hypochondriacs
are quite often people who want
attention from other people there is a
purpose there if they could get that
attention in some other way it wouldn't
go to the doctor's office they figure
that's the best thing for them to do
when we go to the doctor's office I mean
you might like talking with you but if
your doctor came in and just SAT around
he asked with you for a while that's
about it's been nice talking with you'll
see you later would you like that that
would that work for you well let's think
about restaurants you go into a
restaurant same sort of thing happens
the server comes over and says yeah we
have all these great specials this is a
great place to work then they walk off
you're like what were you supposed to do
you're supposed to first what's up let's
do 3k order yeah take the drink order
first right there at least don't bring
out some some water something maybe some
menus and then after a while they should
bring some food if they're not doing
that they're not serving a purpose and
the reason why we want that interaction
with the server is to get the thing that
we want we valued at more highly that's
what he that's what he's saying there
and saying that it's the nature of their
products to be better than the
activities now he also points out
there's a lot of different activities
that were involved in and they can be
arranged in certain hierarchical ways so
that one thing leads to another thing
and you can ask this about just about
anything you want to why are you here
this classroom for example as my
students this all the time sometimes
damp answer sometimes it oh you know why
because a lot of times they have the
phone about mr. following routine why
are you guys here some of you know are
hungry and good event at dinner taking a
damn why this yes first a TPS over here
yeah I notice there's like a whole chain
of different purposes I want this for
this and I want this or that oftentimes
we don't lay these things out and one of
the things that Aristotle calls our
attention to is if we allow these things
just to be sort of dictated to us we're
not going to be as well off as if we
your think about why we're doing the
things that we do and there's a lot of
decisions that we made or ordered sir
but the major us fail to make because we
don't look at what the purposes are and
sometimes the purposes could be a bit
misleading we may think that we're doing
one sort of thing and it turns out that
really we want to be doing another
server will get some examples of that in
a few minutes now let's let's think of
some actual examples think about
something that's an intimate part of
your life here brigade de cuisine right
what is the whole purpose of that what's
what's the whole point one is the idea
of brigade is to not you know overworked
a station and then overworked as in
you're making things twice whereas
you know when you cannot forget forget
system it was you know when you go from
socialization and then be separated you
know crap eschewed area so you can find
all these things and you say you know
like you have your expedite or whatever
and he's firing off tickets and he's
looking under the guy who write you
something's gotta left other than like
they have whatever however system they
had yeah vs now we have printers and
it's like and we can feel the micros
machine you hear that you hear that
rattling they're only here to get in
your life but you know you and you you
have this expediter and he's he's either
you know on one side lying about
basically comes down to is he's like
okay I expired this you know and I'll
trace fire this and fish guy do whatever
going to do and then the whole idea of
that was in order for one thing to line
in the other it was productivity and
you're saving I mean to go to dollars
time Chuck fishing yeah what is it's
very nice summary right there none of us
there's a bunch of different purposes
Los Angeles is it adaptable to
everything where did it okay for start
the start date when we start doing it at
home you don't need it what what kind of
response yeah large larger ones anyone
knows the specifics goods yeah that's a
hotel right so a certain kind of
clientele a certain kind of environment
brought about this reorganization
structure and notice it's what we call a
teleological is what Aristotle talk
about you have food at the top I'm not
gonna drop the whole thing the exec
i'm daniel its kind of it you know shot
scenes person in charge your eggs come
true for french shut-ins chief home
buddy secondary i'm not going to all my
stuff in you can go down the entire line
in planes and you have different
specializations right different
different arts different skills does
everybody know all the skills will soon
yeah but it's pretty rare that you
actually have a one person who can do
everything you can any given field yeah
that's where we get to something
interesting now if you're one of the
specialists here you're working with
that sort of thing all the time aren't
you you think the executive chef that he
has the same level of skill as it could
where she could there's no way there's
only 24 hours of the day you actually
have to sleep the song that you have to
do other things you can't do crazy and
constantly even the you know the
desertion can't follow every single
thing that's right they should have a
lot of skills and they should have them
in general but they may not have them
home to the same abilities that somebody
who's actually doing something whatever
i was talking about which is really
interesting he uses examples like in a
horsemanship and rhetoric and political
science and all that stuff you can think
of it in terms of the brigade
the executive chef have to have some
other skills air assault would call
architectonic skills meaning the skills
that sort of guide everything else
people don't have to have this level
would they need managerial skills just
to be able to mean from you know if he
has an owner he has some he has to he
has room for two and he has to be the
middle guy in between his studiously for
middle managers versus you know the
lenders or design goal or whatever and
having personally upside down triangle
yeah yeah you notice these are
legitimate skills down here but none of
them are going to suffice for doing what
needs to be done up here Aristotle
points out these skills can be arranged
in a [ __ ] Irish and I think the brigade
cuisine illustrates this very well so
when you get road your pieces on what
would you call them this we believe and
you are listing the qualities that a
great chef you don't say executive chef
will soon didn't actually say that when
assuming that's what you meant some of
those were managerial skills that you
talked about the ability to determine
what to do not just in one context but
with the people how to actually manage
the skills of others these skills feed
into these the purposes of these feed it
ultimately through the purpose of the
Executive Chef you know what is the
purpose of blood stations just became
initiated officially what's the point
with the fish station
seafood protein around right there you
go and it's as simple as that to do it
well right now just to throw money came
out how we're gonna pick your salad and
then include that includes a lot of
things to know it's not just making
something that's tasty with sea view
it's particularly important that it also
be healthy and not just in the sense of
you know that super rich or something
like that but it's not poisoning here
alright that's one of the hazards what
is the point of that well that feeds
into other things which feed into other
things and ultimately gets to the point
the point gets up to the purpose of
executive chef the purpose of the
executive chef is to tend to entire
restaurant what is the purpose of a
restaurant just to exist for its own
sake okay notice we have a bunch of
different purposes sort of being laid
out here profitability served customer
there was one other one or what's up
hard there's another big one too maybe
not everything sizzling probably equally
it's little clinical
we talk about astronomy yeah or it shut
down so focus on art well yeah and you
have to be able to balance these
different purposes against each other
you can't do that without actually
thinking about what am I trying to
accomplish it what are my purposes and
Aristotle is gearing us towards being
able to think about all these frameworks
in which we place items and any
framework that you can put something you
can probably find another bigger frame
so this classroom you know what's going
on here fits into the scope of your
class and your class visited scope of
like culinary education that fits into
the scope of what preparing culinarians
to go out and work force you notice that
we have these wider and wider sets of
purposes I want to move ahead well
actually before we do that let me you
mentioned one other thing because this
will lead it to the next thing this poll
that you sent me the data for I don't
remember I was dumb
so there was this poll you may did you
tell them about this there's a pool of
culinary students why why are you in
this what's the rebels and the results
are pretty interesting professor Jacques
is this a number of different
conferences to tell people about what's
going on under into culinary 1 out of 10
students said they wanted to be famous
that's understandable right we have this
phenomenon of super shot a celebrity
chef what about a tenth said they wanted
to take care of your family so very
clear economic motives to attend said
they wanted to have their own place one
day well that can be understood in terms
of economic problems i think but also
probably in terms of independence
perhaps in some something similar to
being famous maybe those coincide to
some degree and then 610 said to do what
I love so that's what the cohorts before
you have been saying about what they're
doing here that they want to do what
they love now that could mean a lot of
different things couldn't it how many of
you are here primarily to do anymore
okay now what does that actually mean
to me I mean I've done the house work
I've done office working game testing
mighty stuff nothing is quite as
satisfying that standard line okay
detail that I think this is satisfied
that's not just being gelva because you
could go get that surround the line us
out yeah so sir part of the activity
right little people send almost
everybody what else whatever what does
it mean to other create something of
your hands okay is also he's love later
to be destroyed but that's the idea of I
mean it's it's you know it's the ability
to create something sore hands obviously
and you know physically see pleasure
through somebody else to generate
blender yeah that's there's something
there's really something to that
find something to do with them that's
understandable oh yeah I was gonna say
whereas i can go the accountant attorney
money for some water and technology like
the iphone not something people are
going to need but it's a society we're
always going food well i mean in our
lifetime they're probably opportunity to
count we maintain a broader III mean I
mean it's basic you need yeah that is
something I not just to eat but they
actually happen to taste good again we
come back to ya think I love about it is
you create something and which you
actually got to think deeply about it
and you're creating a dish and when you
serve it people people face it and they
either like it or don't and it's just so
simple for them and that gives me the
luxury to have my own work because they
don't get it they just simply decide
whether if they like it or not yeah so
you can see there's a lot of range and
doing what I love right it can mean a
lot
again we have to come back to you know
what is it Theory actually after it's
very easy to say things like I'm going
to do what I love another day actually
spell that out for yourself and to
figure out what it is that you're
actually driving from those are good
segue into aerosols discussion of
happiness which I'm going to go through
pretty quickly because I actually
consumed far too much time the first
part maybe we'll do Q&A is right after
that Aristotle talks about happiness and
my happiness he doesn't mean just sort
of a temporary being in a good mood or
feeling pleasure necessarily momentarily
or feeling even joy he means something I
didn't were lasting something the greek
word is viewed i'm on the end which
literally means having a good sort of
spirit pervading and it's often been
translated as flourishing we flourish I
think all of you have seen things so
many flourishes those those parts of
themselves that otherwise might sort of
like stagnant they get to unfold they
get to experience what makes them
actually feel fulfilled so that's what
he's talking about with happiness and it
considers a lot of different candidates
for having the hand at one of the handle
today Khafre the second party who
considers a couple different candidates
and you do see people in Aristotle's
time just as in our time
Constance acute nature was up that
second page of the first hand out there
are certain things they gravitate to us
wealth is one of a lot of people think
that making a ton of money or having a
lot of possessions is going to make them
happy Aristotle thinks that's miss
galaxy it's not that you know have money
as bad or pursuing my as bad but why do
we want I mean you know I've got single
dollar each one my fault but that
doesn't make me particularly happy in
have itself and our money you know kind
of drab looking other people's bank
accounts are kind of colorful kind of
the static appeals even with that what
is this good for pleasure we get
Williams or knock off the lot I mean
when I was a kid this is by you like
four packs of going to for candy bars
now maybe one maybe not even that
captions money is only good if you can
exchange it for things even even
possessions their only good so far as
you can use them I mean you can have 20
cars in here in your driveway well you
probably would have to have a parking
lot rather than drive it but you get the
idea you can only drive one car at a
time I mean you could say well I might
all my friends over and then we all
drive around together but there you're
involving more than you and what is it
again what is the purpose there
something bigger than just having lots
of cars it's friendship we're doing
activities together something it's not
having the cars that's really good
fulfilling its what you can do with what
about pleasure just pleasured by itself
is an interesting one to think about for
culinarians because part of your job is
to give on a people pleasure right
you're not successful with people coming
here restaurant and they say I had an
unpleasant experience you feel pleasure
and seeing other people's pleasure right
so maybe pleasure could be the whole
goal maybe just satisfying all of our
desires
for drink and sleep sex all of our
physical desires would be enough
Aristotle thinks there's something
lacking to that and I think you guys
probably YouTube otherwise you would
just be pursuing pleasure D when do your
classroom yeah well I really won't part
with it for pleasure the state of soul
well Aristotle thinks that we're not
just our bodies the soul is what makes
our body of live it's what makes our
body sentient so when we feel pleasure
we often think of it as I'm feeling
pleasure getting coffee for example we
think about it as I'm feeling pleasure
like my tongue because it a lot of
analyses of this exactly as the pleasure
taking place but it's really in my my
person I Who I am I got the g was trying
to say it happiness well he thinks that
in large part in he has to do with your
personality with who you are how you
live I mean he does think you have to
have something so well if you're totally
poor you know if you're living on the
street you're probably not going to be
that happy for yourself he would look at
some other people's conceptions of
happiness for instance Lee about
religious orders people become monks or
nuns and they take these volumes of
poverty aerosol look at that
and then maybe he's wrong about that
because some of them report being quite
happy he also fixing any dead friends
and hopefully family you can't when you
say about self-sufficiency he doesn't
mean you go off you live by yourself
like a miser or somebody you know the
compound and farm water yeah enough that
you can provide for yourself you can
have connections with other people if
you don't think about what it takes just
to enjoy yourself with other people in
terms of eating and drinking okay all
right you guys to do this all the time
right you cook for each other what would
it be like if somebody said no I'm not
going to put anything into them kidding
I'm not going to bring anything to the
potluck I'm going to do everything on my
own could they participate in these sort
of things up to a point yeah they could
feed a bit then get kicked out well I
mean no I'm saying the other
yeah we there have to be enough so this
goes to this question of whether it's
totally within ourselves there has to be
enough to allow us to actually interact
with other people because for aerosol
other people aren't part of our address
is family second yeah there has to be a
balance between it you couldn't just
derive happiness reality from other
people so Aristotle wouldn't see a life
again maybe there's maybe he's missing
out on something he wouldn't see a life
that's just totally absurdist on their
people as a happy life mother Teresa
seems to be happy hers air assault
occurs he is somewhat restricted by it
by his this time culture let's move on
to another candidate if it's not just
physical pleasure maybe it's something
like honor or prestige that people do
desire this don't thing why open your
own restaurant it could be just to make
a lot of money but there's plenty of
others to make a lot more money that are
a lot more reliable than opening a
restaurant aren't there
he said yeah this is honored pleasure of
reason and every virtue nothing resulted
from memory so truth agent oh there he
is actually talking about what we choose
for their own sakes so erase this when
he speaks about that yeah I get from it
that you're not happy because you're
doing the right things but you're doing
the right thing to become happy now
exact happiness in the broadest sense
so being it comes with actually he's
talking about he's not talking about a
temporal succession you know this
happens and this happens after them he's
talking about a sort of a logical
connection between why we choose this or
why we do that so they happiness for
fulfillment and flourishing this we
choose for its own sake it would be
crazy to say I'm going to choose to be
happy so i can make a ton of money that
would be like totally backwards
priorities right there are a lot of
other things that we do choose for their
own sake you know people choose a lot of
plungers and if you ask them why are you
engaging that player because it's
pleasant so that's for its own sake
you're watching TV which I think
probably almost find Pleasant we saw
some shows why are you watching the show
when you made it something you know they
went I'm going to do a book report on
this later on
but usually why are we watching it
welcome enjoy we're driving
entertainment if you're if you're doing
that that's going to think make you
happy then you're actually pursuing
pleasure for the sake of happiness but
you also want the pleasure to it's not
like you only want the pleasure because
it can happens you want the pleasure
because you think that's what happiness
is same thing with honor people can
defer an awful lot of pleasure so that
they contain a certain status or
prestige and why do they do that well
because they think the debt honor
whatever else you want to call it is
going to make them happy whether they're
right or wrong I mean a lot of that you
can look at experientially look at other
people's lives and see whether pursuing
this kind of life actually does make and
then he talks about wisdom or knowledge
invest why do people say become college
professors panal
other things you can do with an advanced
degree when times get an MBA it's done
make a ton of money man well because you
know like reading books talking about
this kind of stuff thinking about but
why well because we think that's going
to make us happy and you know and if it
doesn't make you happy that people will
stop pursuing the sort of thing and
finally he talked about virtue or moral
excellence and virtue you could also
think of broader terms is also what he
calls the intellectual virtues these
crafts your skill and what you do I
think that a lot of you are studying
these things not just as means for men
if you're doing what you love you
actually think it's going to make you
happy you're pursuing it for the sake of
happiness but you're also pursuing it
because you think it's valuable in
itself something that doesn't fit that
would be like well if you think that
wealth by itself is going to make you
happy you're going to have a rough time
ahem Hector this attack repeats here but
if you trade to offer butter people want
to be wealthy to inform ice this is on
fire or that affords on your time to
pursue wisdom or that allows them to
exercise virtue I'm pouring the
addiction
right these are done for the sake of
themselves but also for the sake of
happiness this is really only good sake
something else but really anything that
you're sacrified you're making a
sacrifice you're putting up with
something to get something else it would
be over on this side too so all the
things you don't like about your
culinary education that's over here okay
you're not enjoying it but you realize
that it's good right and they don't give
you wisdom or virtue in reversal so you
do it that's a good question he also
does talk about health and other points
and I guess health would be probably
something over here to health is really
a means to an end it's not the best
thing in and of itself people that only
are concerned with health or something
i'm missing from the DeMars let's now
talk about virtue itself or actually
before we do that any other questions
before you jump into Virginia
happiness do you think that Aristotle
season that's like society or anything
Aristotle things that our happiness is
depends on your personal that's a good
question I would actually say we get our
conception of happiness we get messages
about what we want to take us on
consumption of happiness constantly
thrown at us in our society but yeah we
think about commercials if you just have
this product yeah yeah 30 minutes
segment sequence on they work basically
to it either you get this that's a party
all the time you're like this appeal by
this car it's smooth driving and maybe
we'll run to a wolf you know be kind of
cool word they are they good scary right
and they say if you don't buy this
deodorant people aren't going to like
you and your offer why you don't you
don't buy this detergent your clothes
are gonna be dirty people won't like you
yeah you're constantly getting bombarded
with messages about what happiness
consistent so you have your own
conceptions of happiness that you have
to work out and you're not doing it in a
vacuum and you're not you know
completely unique this as they often
miss snowflake that is totally different
than every other snowflake whoa I mean
we have a certain basic drives in common
there are certain aspects to our
personality that will map on to each
other fairly well so that's why we can
talk about these things in the first
place but experientially we actually do
have a kind of way these things against
each other and you notice you never
actually pursue pleasure per se you
always pursue this
if I have a weakness for co-opting with
that that's a weakness for a particular
kind of pleasure that's not the same
things absent i'm gerry yeah i don't
know if i have a weakness for asset or
not no I would supposed to be very
bitter right no I if you like any
colleagues ritual benefit if it was it a
good be for me and it's the same thing
when we pursue honor when a person
Connor so say we pursue oh I want this
position or this prize and even thing
all the other kinds of wisdom that
develop or the kinds of knowledge that
we developed its its its determinant on
the virtues they can be identified and
if you are courageous and I'm courageous
we have something in common but your
courage is exercised in different
circumstances than mine is and in
different ways so yeah to answer your
question there's there's the part you're
getting from everybody else and then
there's the part that you're getting rid
yourself you may have certain capacities
to Aristotle talks close to the end of
what we were looking at a concert of
natural virtues some of us again use
courage some of us are more naturally
given to say doing things like public
speaking some people are just terrified
and with the bitumen the person who's
terrified can actually overcome that
fear and become courageous but the other
person is a leg up it's easier
some of these may be some of these
answers may be harder to resist for
certain people so that that plays into
it as well this is a good stepping
collective moral virtues as well I'm
going to go through this very good
Aristotle thinks that there are certain
qualities of character that we need in
order to function well as human beings
and it says the virtue of a thing makes
that thing be in good condition and it
also makes that thing good for other
things so if this is in terms of well
let's think about a book what is it for
a book to be in good condition this book
is not it is actually starting to get
out of the right spine starting to break
but you know like I always point out the
words are still in there I can still
read it I can get what I want out of it
that works for for this it's good in its
nature it's also good in the use that I
can make of it it's good for something
what about you well let's look at some
of the qualities that you guys actually
brought up in terms of moral virtues one
of you at remember who said a good chef
should not be a glove you should eat to
live not live to eat if you're a glutton
and you're a chef you're probably going
to be hard to work with aren't you and
this is not the field English you know
if you want to have sort of a disordered
appetite towards food or drink
especially drink if you're here's a
drunk all the time you'd be a good chef
what's that can't be good
cuz I'm are good at drinking games for a
while and you know after a while the
brain yeah that that's the quality that
that's needed now can you if you
actually have weaknesses towards food or
drink or something like that can just
snap your fingers and I'm not going to
do that anymore can you just have an
intention is that going to carry you
through or people talk about having a
passion or making a decision no it has
to become something I'm Mitchell require
some discipline you actually have to
like stand up against temptation say I
really want to do this I'm not going to
do it and then the next time it gets a
little bit easier right next time
eventually you actually want to be that
way that's what it is to acquire a
virtue another good example patience for
one's self then you guys talked about
patience quite a bit patience for
oneself not getting down on sell for not
getting something immediately patients
not just for oneself before everyone
around you and also the patience to
teach those willing to learn identified
that as whether you'd be a great chef or
a great culinarian loss account some of
us are naturally more patient than
others can you develop patience if you
don't have them that would be a virtue
that that would be something that would
actually make you be able to do what it
is that you do well and you know if
you're doing what you do well you will
be happy that's that's why Aristotle
constantly stresses virgin you'll also
have pleasure but you'll have pleasure
is sort of a byproduct doing what it is
that actually fulfills you how did you
put it before the laws of yours or
innate qualities to be developed or
express themselves that would matter
yeah the characteristics okay have
characteristics of a person what the
virtues would do it would be allowed
provided a good characteristics allow
those characteristics to actually be
fully developed and that will make you
so that's a very thumbnail sketch of
virtue let's let's prove because we
don't have a lot of time let's move on
to talk about this practice and voices
thing so that the world more bridges are
some sort of mean involves a habit
requires a lot of you know modeling
after after people what about other
things like your craft Aristotle talks
about the crafts or the skills where the
Arts detect the tec-9 as being a kind of
virtue an intellectual virtue that means
that it's something that you develop if
you're doing a little bit different than
moral virtue and that it could be used
for good or it could be used for bad you
know moral virtues by definition they're
being used for good otherwise nothing
world virtues right could you use your
culinary skills for evil yeah be
Hitler's quick right wasn't yeah you
could poison somebody there is that
there is actually an interesting guy
neck in this 19th century France and his
name was greedy eight and he killed
people by feasting them to death he so
this wouldn't be cooking they'd be
employing other people's culinary skills
he was a great guru mom yeah he would
order up these incredibly rich you know
dishes night after night after night
like you know of course after course
after course I guess he had a lot of
money and he would invite people on for
that form friendships with other epic a
turd and then he would try to get them
to eat as much
rich food as possible so that they would
die that's what got this this guy going
this is a weird he got done in by a
French cavalry man whose reputation was
of course this isn't physically possible
that he had hollow legs r e struct all
the other food because he had this guy
and he actually killed 38 he took out as
a challenge so that would be a very evil
thing to do enough you know necessarily
not the poison I'm just give him a
really Fanny food here's butter yeah I
remember fresh the shocking have you
read Kachin confidential and I that was
a amazed at in for dance description
just hot water is a good-tasting food
now that can't be good for you and you
can extend this to other things too can
your craft you use for good things or
bad thing sure a good example of
somebody using culinary things for
clearly explicitly moral lends Jamie
Oliver going in and try to get people to
adapt healthier diets bars not set that
high there's lunch program since it
giveth but you know anything anything is
an improvement now your skills involve
the same sort of issues about purposes
you can ask for your skills what are
what are the purposes you're trying to
detain with them what is the goal and a
lot of what you're doing is culinarians
is learning how to connect your actions
the sense of actions that you do with
the goals so here we into those sort of
criteria
asking can you ask whether something is
being done well or being done poorly and
skill set that's part of what makes it a
skill part of what else makes it a skill
is that you can't have absolute certain
criteria for it that's what
differentiates it from say a science
there is a kind of here we can also to
judgment there's a need to cultivate the
kind of capacity to judge that can't be
you know turned into something just like
a recipe they can't be purely
technologies I can't remember who wrote
this somebody talked about two kinds of
professionalism one being where it just
becomes like sort of being a cog in the
machine right that would not be the same
thing as what ever saw was talking about
a skill none of you want to follow up to
that to it right yeah you want to be
able to exercise some some creativity
you want to be able to take you know
ingredients before you them to each
other make them fit each other that is
what we ourselves talking about as the
intellectual virtue ases technic of
being able to produce next to go to you
know the question about breaking down
like a wonder what is the side of lamb
or layla going to light when it that's
that's a productive activity you're not
actually making something new sound like
there's any more lamb left at last we
are generating a new product just like
when you're cooking and you're making a
dish you're taking ingredients and
you're producing something and you're
producing more than one thing to this is
something worth keeping in mind as well
yeah it goes to the question of purposes
when you're producing as as a cook as a
chef as a baker anything what are you
actually trying to produce
yeah pleasure these are all right
finished product something that you can
say well that look that's actually
cooked that's that's actually done I
also sometimes I think Brendan turns out
to be still push it like sort of eyeball
what did you say it's our a desirable
product okay why is it desirable because
it produces but but you're actually
seeking the pleasure of another not just
your own very often you actually have to
sacrifice your own pleasure for a while
and sort of things people don't you you
have to put up a lot of pain at times to
produce great queasy you're on you might
do i do you have three states in a day
you're not going to face into space but
you're at the honor of knowing that 20
people had put your knees well at the
same time is visible
too that's a little bit beyond honor
that gets more in the territory of the
version like one of those people who do
we work would you still actually feel
good about it that'd be part of
happiness for you if nobody's actually
coming up and saying a good job because
sometimes you're going to be at
situations where nobody actually
situations so then that look carries you
through is virtue so I can't believe it
well what aerosols going on is something
that comes from decima I mean we can use
terms in a lot of different ways he
means by honor as other people honoring
yeah and so your your your how to put it
your self satisfaction in your craft
would be what you're trading off against
there you could even think of this you
know when you're cooking and it's not in
the restaurant it's just people that you
like they know they may look at you
interesting oh you're just a cook this
is you know you know we have celebrity
chefs people would say something like
that but you could take pride and what
is it you're doing now Aristotle
distinguishes is the last thing on the
time buddy distinguishes between
production or po asus and the action or
doing or praxis and in the selection
that I gave you it looks like the 200
totally incompatible actually let me
read some of the passages that I think
probably we're hanging you up
where he says making an acting being
different park mystery of matter making
them acting so arts what it is that you
do has nothing to do with acting or
praxis or doing in the larger sense
there's nothing to do a practical is
that may give you that impression he
says uses architecture since
architecture is an art and it's
essentially a reason state of capacity
to make there is neither any art that is
not such a state nor any state that is
not such a not an art art is identical
with a state of capacity to make all art
is concerned with coming into being
making something happen something
previews with contriving and considering
how something may come into being which
is capable of being or not being whose
origin is in the maker and out of the
thing made for artists can seem
concerned either with things that are
coming to being by necessity or those
which do that by nature he's havin
themselves this makes it all sound as if
these are totally suckered categories a
better way to think of that because
that's that's one of those passages of
aerosol alergia yet other passages
embarrass level will you make a bit more
sense think of them as being sort of
laid over making a breaking down a rack
of lamb for a light lamp for example
that isn't making you are producing
something can you ask the question why
sure the answer to that might be well
because we need a whole bunch of pieces
that conserve that's clearly a man of
art there are criteria for that did you
do it a sloppy way are you know sound
like you know jumbled up and they look
completely different from each other
because you
exercise technical expertise to do did
you slice them beautifully in just the
right way there are criteria that going
beyond that though we have the realm of
practical wisdom why did you that way
let me think let me give a really easy
example think about the / gauges the
cuisine again if you're at one of the
lower levels what was the purpose there
for you so just to be a cog in the
machine or are you part of something
larger as well as being yeah can you can
you have different reasons for doing
what it is that you're doing that would
interfere with the well functioning of
the machine yeah like what money that
might actually make you work better
right I'll take away your paycheck if
you're hecka don't do what they want
yeah yeah what wondering what might
cause interference with the person next
to you or the person who's taking the
product that you're generating and then
using that in their product taking
you don't think your product and having
praise for it if you were for example
only to do well when somebody is
constantly praising because you desire
it well not only would you not make it
yourself you would screw things up for
everybody hostage and we hope you like
send shockwaves through the whole this
is one of the vulnerabilities you mean
people who can actually work with each
other well is that just a matter of
technical expertise then a matter of
craft are you being able to work well
with other people or is that a matter of
practical wisdom even though just
cutting up a you know a leg of lamb can
be a occasion or think about it as a
locus for you to exercise practical
wisdom practical wisdom is tied in with
these virtues these these traits that
you identified like patients or another
example that you guys have was a
particularly like being humble and not
arrogant being honest and selfless
keeping your promises to yourself or the
ones around here if you're unreliable
you can't really be a part of aggregated
azeem yet of course the fire turn over
but you also will interfere the purposes
of what's going on a lot of it has
identified as these ideals that you want
to strive it can be thought of in terms
of aerosols categories so again think of
your technical expertise as being one
thing that what you produce and that's a
good thing he's not saying it's totally
morally neutral or anything like that
it's a good thing to be to be good at
cooking to be good at my butcher to be
good at identifying what things are safe
when things aren't practical wisdom is
something above that then we get into
the distinctively moral domain and that
isn't just a matter of bright lon that's
a matter of how well you steer yourself
towards what's ultimately going to
fulfill you the last thing I want to end
with Aristotle says something yeah and
then we'll do some some Q&A if you guys
want to stick around saying on time the
last thing I want to focus on he dealt
lay out an ideal for it he says all the
states we've considered converged to the
same point when I speak of judgment and
understanding and practical wisdom we
credit the same people with possessing
judgment and have you reached years of
reason with having practical wisdom and
understanding because all these things
deal with the ultimate which are what
the particulars particulars don't mean
you know abstract things out there that
means your life your actual your
progression it's one thing to have sort
of abstract ideals is another to realize
that in practice and Aristotle is
talking about tying all these things
together in practical Lisbon was going
to steer you towards what's going to
fulfill your it's going to make you
happy so this puts it in kind of an
interesting Kramer you may not have
thought about before and this isn't sort
of the end point I only gave you certain
we don't just really scratched the
surface with Aristotle so this gives you
some things that may help you to think
about
to work on your statements of belief
let's do some Q&A or any other things
that are bothering ya why is writing but
why it's wise is so happiness important
Oh Aristotle thinks that that's sort of
a question that doesn't have any answer
because even the pose it is to the
survey asking why are we human beings do
you think means we just do in fact
desire to be happy we don't always have
the best idea of what it is there's some
people being happy means getting in
counseling other people and having
something to complain about that's sort
of a diminished notion happens so yeah
there's art there are always something
that's one of them for years
it's hard it actually is a struggle
drive yeah because you know as a
philosopher Idaho mr. things together
and I tried to think my way around this
well can you can you find some example
of somebody who really doesn't want to
be happy but usually when you do that it
turns out well they've got this
distorted conception of happiness that
consists of the way I didn't think about
some of you likes people beating them
masochist right right why do they like
that well they get a charge out right
which leads us again to like being happy
is my [ __ ] reach the question is does it
turn around that happiness is the best
thing for us it's in my google one hmm
but the best thing for us as individuals
or that political sense yeah so you know
that's again that's one of the strengths
of Aristotle's view if you have a
distorted conception in happiness like
if you think it's just pleasure so the
question of whether let's say you've got
happiness but it wasn't a good thing for
you you couldn't have you happiness in
the full sense without being a good
thing because you couldn't actually make
it there without having develop your
your personality to be able to to
appreciate it again issues are unfolding
these things that are within you which
you know it could mean that we don't
actually enjoy full happens he says
anything about you're not really
happiness your contributor
he means us one society or yeah yeah
yeah I think Aristotle certainly thought
we're we're social animals we need to be
in relationships with other people level
the family and then at the larger level
are our society and also traditional
friendship and if you if you don't have
good relations with other people and
park is not a good person doing bad
things you're not going to really be
happy again you can think about this in
there's all these temptations in the
kitchen right there exploit people to
you guys talked about some of these in
your statements about what first what
not to do does it take advantage of
other people is honest doesn't this make
them will be a lot of temptations
towards things which could interfere
with you ultimately attaining happiness
very good yeah it's this thing about the
life of money-making is gonna take like
under compulsion yes I mean like I don't
think somebody's holding a gun no I know
I'm not in order for me not to wither
into my body eating its own fat I have
to make money sure in order to yeah and
then you know and like it goes on say
some other things
just like so rough that you know and
then what these things being said let us
leave the subject it's like yeah well
we'll be here with your cell are a lot
of sort of outlines right and then I
guess also there's a lot that's left out
because it translation is that no the
translations are the translations are
having things every thurs garble oh yeah
they get to onion that you know in the
way that they are translated into the
ash language is as far as the issue
about the life of money-making what do
you means there he's not talking about
whether you have to earn money or not
he's saying a life that's centered
around yeah so a life of pleasure is
like this fundamentally senator not
pleasure doesn't mean it doesn't you get
pleasure from making money is well the
life of money-making would be you that's
that's all you're really about sure
that's the same focus and then you know
really as is the health nut is its
pleasure up exactly yeah they're losing
sight of some of the other things now
here are some things that some people
are going to be forced to us absolutely
and 11 of the blind spots in Aristotle
that I did point out he does think that
most people that are involved with the
crafts can't really live the full
happy life in part because we're mainly
involved shining money yeah I mean
that's the whole thing too is like in
our industry it says you know first one
is to you know the property second is to
the guests third is to you know whatever
else it is and forth is to yourself if
that's even possible as far as like
duties or going to be an obligation yeah
well this then we've actually talked
about this there the culinary industry
by its very nature is very hard and
there's there's kind of this goes to
that question too about where do you get
your mobile consumption from your
environment enlarge the culinary
environment is constantly stressing you
have to fit in your part of you know
this is largely thing that maybe doesn't
actually allow you to lunch a chance to
ask these questions that what are the
purposes here what am I actually
for allows that only the washer for once
you attain sort of superstars right but
then are they happy I mean well I mean I
know that most of them are I mean yeah
well I suspect that a lot of the
superstar chefs are actually motivated
primarily by well I mean this is
reversal yeah but they're not looking
for you individually well yeah but I'm
going to add a certain time I would
think that they would be no because I'm
other people looking obvious a good
person in this sensor that sense what do
you are yeah yeah yeah so these one of
you chefs that you have honored
necessity results and I mean you just
put something out who we want to be
honored by people who we actually care
about yeah but nothing said that
sometimes you know who it said yet
that's exactly right is who who are you
looking for you know to be proud of or
for you to be proud of what Jim yeah
yeah sorry other questions or issues yet
he has more questions that he gives me I
think he I think he opens up to
questions and then he considers that one
gender Frank lini then even considers a
bunch of different peoples the answers
to them and he wants to see what's
what's valuable in done and what's not I
would be see what I'd be willing to say
as he leaves some questions hold that
this goes to complaint because of
because he doesn't actually like go into
great detail yeah nice nice
stories he tells you the story but
please you to make up the ending for you
know I think it's more structured with
that maybe he has a person for the truth
say up the truth well he is he was
trying to pursue truth yeah they're
actually herself nice quip you know he
disagreed with his teacher play-doh he
studied with for 20 years so if you must
like the guy and he said at one point
where he's disagreed with the play-doh
well we was love our friends but we must
love truth even more and I'm flying
trick play know what's wrong about this
you have to go with with truth the truth
is complex he looked on the particulars
first and then tried to write nul to
food from that rather than looking from
the outside that's the sort of textbook
thing that they do more complicated than
now oftentimes you
to the universal and look at particulars
sort of it back of the court Plato
wasn't always just looking at the
universal you have to work your way from
particular too because I guess we have
no like a key equipment Leah can't have
that complete you can live vegan
University for aerosol for us oh sure he
thinks we do it just takes a lot of work
and we we always do it within the
context of our own life so that's why
you uses so many examples Thank You
major put it in working at the example
the idea is to try to get
you mean about human beings yeah you
know there's a lot of views of human
beings that see us is not be having a
function well then that would be like
purely individualism we'd have a be a
part of post-modernism you don't even
have to go as far as post-modernism that
just traditional liberalism not not in
the political sense but in philosophical
sense it begins from the idea that we
have no comment no comment sort of
structure that we can look at oh no
common function we should just sort of
figure it out on our own it's one thing
to say that there actually is something
we be a mat and we each have to figure
it out but we're actually aiming at the
same thing it's another to say it's like
totally up for grabs and we all just
kind of come up with our own
interpretation and yet post-modernism
does do that but you don't have to go as
far as it jean-paul Sartre was saying
something like them as saying that we
create our own essence of us
yeah but yeah there there are a lot of
viewpoints that say look we really have
nothing in common with each other we
can't talk about these these overarching
moral questions because we begin from
disagreement that we can never reach any
sort of agreement if that's the case
then we're pretty much stock and then it
turns it usually what happens in this is
where post waters and goes it just turns
into the plate power is mine my
interpretation dominates yours because I
got the PhD and you don't you know why
I'm in charge of the kitchen and you're
not where you anything along those mice
what is the ethics and I certainly don't
want to go there I don't think any of
you do oh do don't let me get stuck
under that big surging the study of like
what ought to be and moral more like
what it is in like different cultures of
humans well again that's one of those
things that they say in text books but
ethics and morals are actually the same
f those is the Greek term more races the
Latin term and sometimes we contrast
them some textbook writers have like to
say well there's moral codes and those
you know are fat those are just
statements of fact and then there's
ethics as the study of going about to be
somebody like Aristotle would recognize
that distinction that's a good late
modern distinction certainly not agreed
on by all philosophers
any other questions or I think gum
subtle kind of touched on the subject of
like the human nature massive many quite
slavish to their tastes I bring a laptop
suitable to East's and like the bridge
you like the nature of man is quite the
contrary of what we think is virtue well
there's nature and a couple different
scents yes there's there's nature in the
sense of where things currently our plan
and you're just think that the majority
of people are making that choices when
it comes to evaluating and which of
these relapse pursuit but that's not
nature of the full sense to actually
develop virtue for Aristotle is to
develop human nature we have the
capacity for virtue for cultivating
parts of ourselves that may just remain
potential until we actually make them
actual and do that is in a certain way
to be more human than our starting point
so leg it says with with respect to the
virtues none of us are naturally
courageous or just or have good tempers
we have the capacity for example to feel
anger or the capacity to feel fear then
we can act in certain ways towards it
and we don't already have the habit
built up when we're born
managing your anger welcome or managing
my fear well maybe you ought to we have
to develop that over time but to do that
to acquire virtue is to realize human
nature so there's there's nature of the
sense of like our starting point which
is not very good a lot of people to stay
at the starting point right or they even
become worse they become vicious and
then there's nature in the sense of what
we're actually shooting what our goal
he also was peculiar to ya for human
beings every time you see me on because
of the sort of i mean it's translated by
these these people back at the time when
that was fine too he says what is
peculiar to man it makes me think that
he's asking like what's different about
being compared to other animals right
and to me is our ability to ask
questions I mean animals don't question
why things happen they don't like thirst
for knowledge aegis at Penn State yeah
I've said this another class as a dog
doesn't actually ask itself am I a good
dog well I mean a dog does raise such
certain questions for itself doesn't ask
itself those questions but it doesn't do
things like what's that over there eat
this let me try it you know via a lot of
it is based instead value experience
though I yeah it actually I had cast
that could grasp the concept of
punishment the dominant cat started
punishing the other kids when they got
in trouble she would go out to them you
know after ever be like yelled at or
squirted them she'd go up to the top so
they can get some human concepts for
they big you're right they don't ask
questions about you know dogs don't say
what is Ferris no but it's not just
asking the questions that is important
it's it's answering you know because if
all you do is ask questions you know you
never get it done
right but think about this in terms of
culinary's no other animals really do a
lot of cooking I mean you can say that
some of them do some things that modify
the food that they're eating not and I'm
not just talking about like you know
otters breaking open you know the shells
or things like that some do a few things
that actually modify the taste of what
the game but none of them have culinary
arts that's distinctive they don't go
they usually that's what usually gets
them in trouble as they don't go well
I've been following your instincts come
get a lot of trouble wouldn't that be a
danger to I guess the idea of
self-actualization if you just followed
your instincts yes yeah because our
instincts usually tell us things like a
person insulted let me go attack or
they're awfully nice looking let me see
if I can you know get in bed with them
that looks appetizing well we need as
much of it as I can but I meant by
getting us some trouble was like when a
woman looks at a guy and it's like oh
he's probably trouble but doesn't go
with their instincts just goes out with
him anyways yeah that's what I meant by
a lot of people don't follow that in six
months who doesn't doesn't will be
conscious yeah she's following one
instinct but ignoring another one
because she has a desire to be in a
relationship but yeah you know this is a
total sidetrack issue I used to teach in
a prison maximum security
and I can tell you from like looking up
the records of some of the guys that
that I ice to teach when you get that
sort of you know the backyard neck can
hair standing up you get a weird feeling
about somebody you ought to trust that
because because there is something
screwed up about them usually and
psychologists have actually born in
South studies as sociopaths do creep us
out he want to follow when you have that
feeling that there's something off about
that person you want to follow that feel
I cannot to say well I should give them
a nice given just as much of a chance as
everybody else well the guy points out
of in the movie this guy sneaks into his
house and he steals a knife from them in
case he comes in there to like it defend
himself and then he he gets out of house
before the owner of the house fits in
okay and he's hiding the bushes and then
the guy sees him and he suspects that
you know if he comes with a house where
the guy says oh well come in the house
will have a drink and talk I haven't
seen you in a while then once it's in
there and ties the guy up which is why
didn't you follow your instinct like we
knew that so I was up me asking you but
he's still women anyways yeah
I haven't seen you see this because
there's two like the high fells Gator as
you did yeah the other one I have the
first one though ray in the story the
american version is much it's not as
graphic Oh as I've heard it was very
graphic but I love your which one less
graphic than any other person did we
figure out the like a lamb Rachel I like
they really I don't know I was also kind
of confused if you like that led us
astray praxis thing I was just kind of
confused with the definition of what it
wants yeah a big part of that is my
fault though right because we were
focusing on judgment in the room and i
think you know i did mention that too
and your judgments a separate issue
right but we were looking at you know
when it's the ability to taste wine and
you know through evaluated well yeah
that we should have been focusing on to
do it well not kind of the evaluation
piece perhaps but i think i let us to
strain that conversation is it a little
worker to you now both sort of a
contractor yeah they get a lot never in
the room to make sense right I don't one
of my questions is also can you have
both with them after sex right yes
that's what you can have some things
that are both and actually there's two
ways you can have a case where a a
praxis takes in products and that's how
you manage them Aristotle
all these things that are old-fashioned
is being produced in the house all
places and then how do you how do you
manage that's that's praxis and you can
have cases where yeah you in the same
action depending on which way you look
at it could be just production or it
could also be Francis there's one of the
things I wanted to bring up there we got
was an example not for Marysol but by
this guy Eve Simone's versatil Ian he's
talking about playing a piano and he's
distinguishing between different ways in
which we can use the piano you give it a
great piano player so do matter of
choice of sugars and beautiful music
right because you have a skill now if
you're doing that and you're playing
lots of Hampton music right next door
with apartment within walls to your
neighbor just have a death in the family
your your skill is really great but
you're doing a bad thing right and so
there's there's two different levels of
evaluation it's good skill oasis it's
good what your product is being produced
according to us or the rules of the
craft or whatever you whatever you want
and there may be a lot of nuances where
you can't quite put your finger on what
it makes a good piano player but you're
using it for badass you're not using it
for the purposes of human life you're
actually being a jerk right that would
be a case where the praxis is bad for
doing is bad
we're like you know you cut up like a
lamb really well and then you cut it up
really well just so that you can stick
it to somebody else to show that come
hearings must get in some sort of things
like this one thing that we took from
the balut a book that I showed you the
letters to a Hannah chef and it seemed
to resonate with everybody in the
classroom but when you were talking
about sort of critique and criticism he
said praise in the kitchen is the
absence of criticism oh yeah that's talk
no I know but we all kind of black
Dawn's with for various reasons you know
that idea of being able to relate to it
so that would be done without without
positive praise as a reinforcement you
know
of course we do that in academia to the
practice of the crisis thing yesterday
everything think about when you were
talking at the beginning of this
discussion the misconception with
philosophy oh well because when I
thought about it I was like well you
can't do anything about judging what
you're doing to get the ended up that
you want so if I even think of what you
said how people think the philosophy has
justice in the cycle where there's
nothing wrong with me right everything
basically you know yeah one of the
things I had to learn as a philosopher
that had to do with my own wall
development was how not to be driven
into a rage after hearing that like time
after time after time I got you know
but yeah they used to just drive me nuts
because if that's the case of why are
you talking in the first place yeah it's
all just opinions in every opinion is
just as good as anyone else let's all
just shut up no none of them mean
anything like argument like we don't
know what this chair is real or not yes
a good thing yeah working there were
philosophers who really exercise
themselves a little bit over that in the
early part of the 20th century yeah and
then you look at their stuff in your
life and I'm going back to aerosol
because at least he talked about
something but yeah the people they might
say they this might be so but they still
hold on two different the props of
meanings so they could function in life
yeah like the one you wouldn't on the
board that happiness at times so you
know David Hume was famous skeptic
philosopher and he was kind of a great
example because he compartmentalized
things you know he here's what I'll
undermine the whole notion of cause and
effect didn't really do it but at least
convince a lot of people in Europe at
the time and then he said this is fine
while I'm in my study but then as soon
as I go in my billiards room I you know
I just put this aside and I play pool
you know I think that when I do in this
bond will knock the other volume of the
pocket when I was in the box of like
thinking that the cosmos is all there is
all that will be
you know that ever was yeah it just
ended up in there is no free will oh if
you yet if you hold that position that
that's the position we call determinism
it becomes very difficult or morning to
church you know Andrew yeah that idea
some of the other things
great game tournament without sort of
frigging an expert on one particular
well plus for salary church doctor right
yeah just a handsome yeah okay and
there's a once the latin for it the free
will well they just from the de Libertad
a arbitrary choice of the world I can't
where'd that dude out of it but we'll go
some other philosophical readings to do
things on you know it may be a
recommended reading list for starting on
you know another thing I could do is I
could yeah I could push stuff Plato
hated cook cooker he did that yeah i
could post some stuff about that as well
he like compared it to another trigger
me yeah yeah bc plato thought that that
I mean you probably do like all some of
what coloring people are doing it this
medicine yeah all over history yeah and
then all about putting tons of butter
into things that makes it taste good he
saw that is like being the equivalent of
putting makeup on people to make them
look attractive even though they're not
I think da Vinci had some kind of a
similar idea dinky buckaroo yes let's go
cheap taste what it should be interest
yeah yeah that makes sense Tony look at
like his studies of the form oh yeah you
know he was there in the naturalism not
all the adornment yeah so yeah it should
be you know Aristotle actually was
reputed to enjoy fish dishes quite a
loss sort of a weakness for that and to
like to go to dinner parties too much
well not everybody I mean some of the
ancient blasters are kind of extension